[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
now you had never seen game of thrones
and you you were probably one of those
like i refused to watch it yep it was
like a cell phone to me yeah right
right so that cell phone denier yeah
yeah so now that you watch it you're
going do you like it let's rock baby
i'll say this it's good i think a lot of
it is not uh
it's not historically accurate
this is just a scarf
this is like a wintertime piece more for
you know
when you want to just kind of keep a
little bit of the elements off your neck
right
and uh huh yeah debris anything
keep your uh keeps your mullet warm too
[ __ ] yeah so i got that with the bling
gang piece bruh
somebody made this for me yeah
uh what does gang gang mean bro it just
means gang two times in case somebody
didn't hear you the first time aha right
right for people with learning
disabilities yeah learning disabilities
in their ears right and um
i hardly have any feelings left in my
penis anymore i feel like at this age
to be honest with you oh really and i'm
not trying to be weird is it because of
a lot of masturbation or you you get a
lot of girls i think it's a mix of
everything man you know i've been with
some decent women and some just
troubled women and some undervalued
women
yeah um
and you still you still hook up with the
ugly ones or what no these days i mean
you know i try to find uh
that you know a little bit of beauty in
everybody but sometimes you got to
really get in there to see it you know
i also don't want my funeral before
because what if no one shows up
oh no no no because if i died
right
stevie's gonna freaking show up dude
she's gonna go i know but i do i want
like if i'm in town i'm gonna go dude
people are gonna go if you're a town all
right all right that's a good question i
don't know what my schedule is i
understand that but i'm going to ask you
right right now yeah what and i want you
the honest [ __ ] answer okay because
we're bros right
yeah okay i want honest answers from you
okay
so what would you cancel
right
mm-hmm to go to my funeral oh i'd
definitely cancel my own wedding if i
had if i was freaking getting married
okay that's big what about this would
you would you cancel let's say you sold
out but i can't small waiting for
probably almost anything else yeah
that's all right that's why i [ __ ]
brushed my ass back
weddings
oh yeah i keep getting invited to like
hey you want to do huntington beach yeah
right and that's like they want to come
perform in this abandoned crate and
barrel
yeah or like even like i've had friends
go you know i'm doing a show at my house
yeah for the who your uncle
no i'm not doing it right
have you been invited to those weird
shows oh ari madness invites me all the
time it's like hey you want to come over
to my apartment and see who uh files a
molestation charge against me the next
day
and he changes the name every time it's
like his burrito bash he's like we're
having free burritos somebody stole my
snake last time yeah dude you are
rich now dude
you are [ __ ]
i'm not
i'll tell you why i'm not
i've been saving over the years because
i i do i've been in that condo yeah
saving to be rich
look at you dude huh
i was in that i bet you got ramen made
out of steak in this
i got steak i'm a bastard man it's hard
to make it into that form but
yeah yeah i got people to pound that
[ __ ] out bro yeah a buddy of mine came
through town with some sick ginger bro
and i've so i've been on that for like
two days what do you mean like like real
ginger the root yeah what do you mean
like from hawaii
uh i wouldn't say hawaii
no but you went somewhere closer than
that he came into town are you being
real he came to town this guy with an
actual root
ginger root stuff you can't even close
your eyes dude and then and then you
make a juice out of it is that what you
do some some you eat if you get like
grilling the inside part you eat it um
you juice some of it um you can cut it
up and put it in eggs
but it's strong bro yeah make your neck
grow bro
ginger root yeah ginger ginger
i love ginger myself dude yeah
down the street they used to go there
was a sign that said uh we only have
hawaiian ginger
and that for some reason just because
they put the sign up made it seem even
more potent yeah like you're right if
they hadn't put it on they're like oh
this is regular ginger yeah but they
they it was like a warning we only have
hawaiian ginger yeah which scared the
[ __ ] out of us that's why we drank it
anyway you know man that's a gay maker
right there ginger boy if you had to
pick one spice that's a real gay maker i
think
what do you mean by that man just you
get enough ginger in you man you don't
even see gender really you [ __ ]
yeah yeah i mean
yeah
you'll [ __ ] a damn breeze trying to
you'll try to [ __ ] a breeze past them
yeah
let me let me ask you something man
you're [ __ ] anything that feels thick
around your body
yeah you know when i thought you were
unique bobby was when um you got when
you have that i know you talked about it
on stage when you said you got molested
but the problem is that you do the
[ __ ] funeral before and then what if
you don't die right away yeah and then
six months later you're out of starbucks
and some dude that was at your funeral
sees you yeah and they're like you're
not dead yet yeah yeah some guy banged
your sister after your funeral you're
like hey what are you doing here
yeah you're the kind of guy that tries
to bang at somebody's funeral yeah sicko
cause i dealt with the mentally
handicapped we had a bunch of mentally
handicapped by us when i was growing up
and they were wild too
what do you mean lou said this one man
was a farmer i guess and mostly
livestock so yeah you know living crops
yeah yeah and he um
he
had a couple of mental sons and they
call them mentals
[Laughter]
or autism if somebody had autism that's
when they
had autism but they didn't want to make
it fancy
because autism
sounds so french really right right
so you just have the chism yeah yeah
autism and um he had a couple [ __ ]
sons and i don't mean to say if anybody
is [ __ ] i'm not talking about you
i'm talking about these other [ __ ]
people that i knew when i was growing up
and he uh he had two [ __ ] sons that
would always be on horseback and so they
were
yeah because they were livestockers yeah
yeah yeah and they had all that
listening bro
he had livestock yeah livestock he's too
busy trying to sell himself what do they
do to you anybody anything no well they
had i remember they had a handicap guy
in our neighborhood was mentally
handicapped and he used to
kind of kiss everybody a little and
nobody knew how old he was oh really
yeah i
um
did you do it
i don't remember if i did or not i
probably i think i hugged him or [ __ ]
wrote on his shoulders or something you
look like something you liked the lip
thing you like like lit things on fire
growing up huh
uh
i mean i would like lights light stuff
in the yard or if we got half a you know
something we get a extra half gallon of
gas or kerosene or something we put it
like the ditch up and running all right
yeah yeah do stuff like that my buddy's
car one time we [ __ ] put the tires in
kerosene coated them and lit them all
and he drove down the street real fast
yeah um should we even be talking about
this because i feel like it's going to
get flagged or something on on youtube
oh no he he's he's still alive there was
this dude in my group
there i'm not gonna say his name it
doesn't matter i know okay i'm gonna say
that can i guess one person no you have
to say yes or no all right go ahead i'm
just going to guess
um
let me think
i'll tell you this
if
i'll give you 10 billion dollars jesus
10 billion dollars
he's rich
you know what i owe it's probably
america's money he's probably on loan
isn't it you know what i just got bro
what the core you did earth oh
to make the gravity stop
right here bruh [ __ ] you elon
wow you got that score it's cool bro
yeah good luck keeping that somewhere
yeah great crew's gonna get it you idiot
have you ever had a man do something
like that where you just pulled out his
junk and just started of course i'm a
woman right and is it cool is it scary
what was the vibe when you were involved
in it the first time that happened to me
in america it never happened to me when
i was living in the philippines
surprisingly wow but when i came here i
was on the 181
you know
i was on the 181 bus from um
from pasadena city college oh now i'm
getting hard to out today and it was 9
00 pm and i was with my swim bag and
some guy just and the whole bus was
empty and some guy came into the bus sat
right next to me pulled out his huge
dick and just started stroking it wow
15 years old like this bro
like she was kind of testing like a
[ __ ] lava lamp to see if it was like
expensive you know and another time
there was this guy who seemed like he
was in a he seemed like one of those
like ministers like a religious type
they come hard
and he had his dick on the bus again and
he had he had his dick in between like
his bible like or a book i'm not sure if
it was a bible it looked like a bible
yeah he was just ever so
delicately jerking himself off with it
with a book wow dude it's like using his
psalms you know
theo started doing a jiu jitsu and he's
wondering that's hilarious
that's hilarious
i'm a female straw weight right now
it's just funny that you do jiu jitsu
dude i am not that good at it yeah i can
tell and i'm not don't do it stop it's
ridiculous why because you know because
because you're in cahoots with [ __ ]
shobb and eddie [ __ ] the twister
[ __ ] what that guy's insane what's
his name
eddie uh uh mitchell yeah mitchell eddie
mitchell with the twister oh bryce
mitchell's a killer dude look at you
that you're you have a key and
everything bro dude you look ridiculous
like he is stinking up my car right now
i know dude bro stop doing it dude it's
a fad i had to stop for a week because
some of my ribs got really severely
bruised
so
i've been fighting two women and i'm
almost i'm almost beating one of them
what have you learned to do because i
wrestled in high school
yeah did you know how long your high
school was dude it was different when
you were in high school
they didn't even have like i mean they
didn't have a lot the laws were
different
i know but i still know how to do like a
double leg a single leg and a fireman's
oh dude fireman's is out now you kidding
me it is yeah it's fire persons now oh
okay they changed it they did but when i
met you i went [ __ ]
this white dude right here is he funny
my son go up man dang he sounds very uh
i don't know
one of the latin kings now
i'm not latino
bro just be what you got to be okay
this [ __ ] is he funny or what
right
yeah yeah i saw him
[Music]
his point of view and [ __ ] about like
where he's from and [ __ ] he's pitching
jesus about multiplication about his
uncle and
chimes on the all kinds of [ __ ] dude i
was like dude he's one of us bro yeah
and then i saw him in another time dude
him and i did some uh uh
jerked me off by a dumpster oh yeah and
then i did that yeah
i didn't do that excuse me what we
worked together we worked together where
i had a jerk theo off
oh
i didn't literally jerk him off at a
dumpster dude you do what i do in the
hotel room
i charge money for that
but it was meisner we really i think we
touched
[Laughter]
i made a commitment to um my sponsor
that i wouldn't
masturbate to pornography anymore so
it's been two weeks has it really man
yeah and i have a um
marshmallow factory down there right now
dude it's like yeah it's thick oh yeah
yeah and it's cool you actually seem a
little heartier and a little bit more
resonant i think thank you thank you and
present you would you say what it is i
think uh he looks slimmer
no that's not it
you said heart do you mind i just wanted
the computer i mean i can look it up but
i just want to be
so n-a-n-t
yeah so dude when was the last time you
gone like without unloading president
what does it mean deep clear and
continuing to sound or ring [ __ ] that's
me dang bro i can hit that one on the
heading head bro i need to reinforce or
prolong sound yeah who wants this hammer
bra [ __ ]
put that nail in one swoop
keep that window open i'm gonna look at
it okay
i want to take ayahuasca and and and one
time and just you know
experience it and find but then i'm i'm
paranoid that i'm going to be like a
[ __ ] ayahuasca junkie yeah oh yeah
yeah
eating [ __ ] leaves when people come
by they'll be taking pictures of you
you'll hold on to them and they'll take
a picture of you you know yeah or i'll
have your whole life like peacock hairs
on my head and i'll be like a shaman
yeah completely naked in the forest with
peacock feathers and i'll have like red
like mascara on right yeah and i'll be
like
and just speaking some weird language
and then like you're going to be like
hey you want a podcast
i'm you know um
[Laughter]
you're gonna trip out do you remember
being kind of sensual had you guys been
drinking or was it no we don't drink i
don't drink i don't know i don't drink
that's true i forgot yeah yeah do you do
but now had you been drinking and you
had maybe some tea or something or what
does she have to be drugged out to [ __ ]
me or what is that what you're saying
that she has to be in some sort of state
a drunken state for me or a coma or
something
she's gonna let some guy drive down long
beach in a [ __ ] dirty car i wouldn't
be surprised if she has a [ __ ] you
know a couple of [ __ ] mick ultras
bruh for the [ __ ]
your dick is fine bro oh it's not that
great i know i mean but it's like
it's it's hit or miss you know
but visually it looks like a kind of a
sweet potato
you have that sweet potato the shape
isn't weird huh the shape is weird no
the shape i feel like is pretty hearty i
feel like it's a little too hearty you
know
it looks fully edible yeah but it's
fully edible like you'll see like yeah
sometimes i'll wake up in the morning
and it'll have like toothpicks
some kid will have set it by the window
yeah yeah you know like it's uh yeah at
a science fair
yeah my dick is uh
my deck is not a fresh product you know
i mean it's been through several wars oh
it's aftermarket right
if you look closely there's two purple
hearts on it because it's uh survived
too warm
oh really yeah it's decorated brah i
thought it was supposed to be twins but
it's like really premature
maybe oh you think that's
you think that's my underdeveloped twin
out of my dick bruh
maybe i could see you bro get a little
bit of hair installed on the top
i saw this documentary last night for
about 20 minutes it's about
uh
the people
it's basically like five jewish guys
that made tick-tock
and
facebook like button
um it's like programmers or something
right yeah and
and just about the dilemma that they're
all facing in dealing with is this
ethical or not yeah dude i just before i
was telling you about that documentary
so the social dilemma that's what you
saw
oh social dilemma
yeah my bad so you [ __ ] saw it i saw
20 minutes of it dude i didn't want you
to say that
let me explain to you what the [ __ ] it
is and then you're like and then you
were like before
say it man or have nick bring up a
picture what do you think nick's here
for
yeah but you didn't know what it was
called yeah no i didn't and i did
bring up
oh my bad
you so you did know oh i'll tell you
this bro oh yeah yeah last time i come
to this [ __ ] birthday party
yeah where i get attacked bro one of
them eventually got injured
i guess he got injured somehow and then
they got him a bicycle that had a
one of those you know mothers used to
have the bicycle with that baby seat on
the back yeah yeah yeah with that small
baby seat like now they put you in like
this covered conestoga wagon and like
you're like there's like roll bars and
stuff like i remember back in the day
you used to like the kid would just be
like he would just be back there in the
back yeah yeah yeah
the world is still like that yeah yeah
like not even in the mother's sights
like yeah
yeah good luck back to here dude when i
was in thailand just real quick i saw a
dude on a moped right he was wearing
this [ __ ] motorcycle helmet
he had a baby on his shoulder baby had
no helmet that's beautiful
you might as well just take the helmet
officer and just tie your baby to your
head yeah
use the baby as the helmet
right i mean
yeah that's fate practice right there
dude
you don't put a helmet on a baby yeah
that's risky right it's just like angry
white people with bull horns dude blm's
got those rallies have gotten so bad
black people aren't even showing up at
him anymore
they are no black black people like this
[ __ ] is lame as [ __ ] dude
if i was single and you and i were on
the road and like the hardest chick was
like i'll [ __ ] both of you you wouldn't
do it with me
i guess i would do it if
you
one of us would have to like wear a
sheet or something i feel like or wear
like a like a klansman
no no no no
no no i'll dress like i'll dress as
clams right now
i'll take she used to put a little hole
yeah
all right i mean you don't have to say
claims are you going to say a ghost no i
don't know i want to clap dude i prefer
the term ghost that no because i'll have
the purple the purple
yeah i'll be the grand wizard yeah i say
ghost that's not for everybody you know
that's more of my term this mushroom
bull haircut
everybody got everybody gonna wear these
right and it was some sort of government
law or some [ __ ] so now everyone's got a
bowl on their hand click click click
click right they all look like [ __ ]
ghetto [ __ ] beetles or whatever right
where at
in china in asia wherever bro you're
never
it's only when the k-pop star started
going crazy with the [ __ ] rooster
hairs
he tried to change it you know you
should testify this in the impeachment
here he just makes noise
it would fit right in bro i have eyes i
look at myself in the mirror yeah and i
don't go hey like fonzie right i just go
you know what i mean
but like and so when i was at that
coffee shop with her the first day
it was a long couch we're sitting on
and she was really close to me and she
just
locked eyes with me and she was
literally interested about everything i
was saying oh it would scare me yeah and
she was hot too so i was like
oh this what the [ __ ] you know i was
hard yeah oh my god yeah yeah my dick
got hard it's hard now oh that's good
you can't tell through the jeans you
can't tell
yeah i couldn't imagine telling at all
but i think that's cool i like to i if
i'm hard i tell people in the room now
because i don't want to cry i'm not uh
not doing it right right you'll be able
to tell with those pants you'll be able
to oh yeah i'm not your junk is that
pretty clear too i got that [ __ ]
sleeping bird look man you know yeah
yeah that's how my dick rolls down
big tiger valley fan here
um i'm crossing the tracks you've seen
the new
reboot karate kid reboot
what you think of it
and if you would make a guest appearance
as mr miyagi
game game
thank you for your question brother i
appreciate that man i appreciate you
being obviously this guy i'm gonna go
out on a limb
and say this guy is filipino
or
athletic
and relaxed dominican
[Laughter]
and he wants to know if you'd be mr
miyagi and the wildest thing is bobby i
thought about that a minute ago i said i
wonder if bobby's been approached
about being uh
going yagi going full
[Music]
it's yogi dark place
[Music]